Okay. Hello, I'm Linda you and you kinda miss that broadcaster.
Welcome to this episode of the intelligence squared business podcast.
I'm joined by David Epstein to discuss his new book range.
Why generalists triumph in a specialized world?
David is a New York times best selling author who also wrote the sports dream.
He has worked as an investigative reporter for a pro Publica and senior
writer for sports illustrated. Welcome David.
It's lovely to have you here to speak with you about this terrific book.
I'm going to just kick off and ask you, um,
what led you to write this book and after reading it,
I felt it had personal resonance for you. Didn't it?
It definitely did. I mean, I think even when I don't realize it at the time,
in retrospect, I think a lot of my writing projects come out of things.
I'm curious about that I, that I see in my own life.
And particularly though the Genesis of range came out of my
first book, the sports gene,
where I sort of criticized some of the science,
the rigor of the science underlying the so-called 10,000 hours rule or the
deliberate practice framework as scientists call it.
And that brought me into a debate with Malcolm Gladwell, um,
at something called the MIT Sloan sports analytics conference.
And we were brought there to debate about the best way to develop athletes and,
uh, I'd never met him before. Um,
and he's obviously pretty clever and I didn't wanna get embarrassed on stage.
So I went through his writing to, to try to guess what he would argue.
And I saw,
I was writing about how important it was to specialize early in narrowly.
And so when we got to that debate, I,
I made a big point of the data showing that in fact,
athletes who go on to become elite, usually don't do that.
They have this sort of so-called sampling period where they do sort of variety
of physical activities. They gain these broad general skills,
learn about their interests and abilities and delay specializing until later
than peers who plateau at lower levels. And when we were coming off the stage,
he said, you know, that that data really didn't comport with,
with my thinking,
like what you want to go on a run tomorrow when we're both back home in New York
and we'll talk about it more.
And so we became running buddies and we would talk about this stuff on our own
time. Um, and you know, CA called it the Roger versus tiger problem,
which turned out to be the introduction of the book came directly out of our
discussions. And so just as we were talking about it,
w w I started to think about it,
whether what we were seeing in sports could really be just an analogy for other
domains of work in the world. And so I started getting interested in all these,
these other domains and seeing which of those sort of fit that surprising
pattern in sports and which didn't, and that,
that was the Genesis of the project.
And for you personally, you sample didn't, you, you didn't specialize early.
Oh, no, absolutely. I mean, you know, in sports and in life, right?
It's like American football, basketball, baseball,
cross country track and sports. I ran track in college, but I was,
when I was like 16, I, I knew exactly what I wanted to do.
I was going to be a test pilot.
I was going to go to the United States air force Academy.
I was at the end going to be an astronaut. I didn't do any of that stuff. Now.
I have no idea.
Like I've gotten almost linearly less knowing what I'm doing as I've gotten
older. And in, in university, I, um, was training to be a scientist.
So I have a master's degree in environmental sciences. Um,
but I decided that, you know, that wasn't kind of a,
a fit for me. It wasn't good, you know, some economists call it match quality,
the degree of fit between my interests and abilities and,
and the work I was doing. And I sort of decided because of some,
some kind of personal events to try to merge my interests in sports and
science, and, and at the time write about sudden cardiac death in athletes.
Cause I'd had a training partner who had died at the end of a race.
So I took my sort of scientific background where I was like very normal as I was
like living up in the Arctic, you know, doing research in the Arctic Tundra.
And I was a very normal, I would say, around other scientists,
but then you take those skills, move them over to like a sports magazine.
And suddenly I realized how unique that was,
even though it was ordinary in one area.
And so actually that attuned me to something that I just continued to do
throughout my career,
which is take skills that were sort of ordinary in one mill you and, and,
and transport them to somewhere where suddenly they were seen as like, you know,
innovative and creative. And so, um, I did realize that that was something that,
that started helping me. And so I've zigzagged like crazy,
and I'm still doing that.
I still like truly have no idea what I'm going to be when I grow up.
That's actually a very good intro to your book, because it's all about, um,
this, you know, thinking differently, I think about, um,
how you undertake your career. Um,
and I love this quote that you start with and you get the full quote,
a Jack of all trades is a master of none,
but oftentimes better than a master of one.
So tell us about this quote and the premise of your book a bit more that,
that quote.
So usually we only hear Jack of all trades master of none,
and I thought it's kind of culturally telling that we lop off the end of the
quote, which is oftentimes better than master of one,
this isn't to say that we don't need specialists and of course not.
But I do think it's,
there's all this like cultural mythology that,
that sort of makes people feel bad about having brought interest. And in fact,
the first use of Jack of all trades as an insult,
um, the first written use at least.
So the first one we have record of was Yohanis factotum in,
in new Latin. And it was written by, um,
a playwright who was insulting another young playwright who didn't have formal
higher education, uh,
who was really a poet who was trying to write plays and trying to act and help
run a theater company, copy scripts. And so he said this, you know,
this losers trying to do it all. And, and that loser was William Shakespeare.
So he was the, he was the butt of the first Jack of all trades insult.
Um, but I think that's sort of common because if you look through sort of,
especially, you know, science and technology, innovation history,
but also literature in the arts, these,
these people who are coming with an unusual background that often change a field
are at first denigrated by the people who are sort of, um, you know, the,
the sort of status quo standard bears in, in the field. And so that,
that quote kind of came to be representative, uh, to me of that. But,
but we forget the past half of it just like we only focus on
stories of precocity, right? So w in the book,
when I opened up with Roger Federer and tiger woods,
where Roger Federer did all these sports as a kid and delayed specializing and
tiger obviously specialized early, those are both examples of success.
I didn't dispute that at all, obviously,
but everyone knows the tiger woods story.
And even though Federer is just as famous as an adult, nobody knows his story,
even though it's the norm, according to the science, not the exception, right?
Everyone knows Serena Williams played a lot. As, as a girl,
I got to talk to her last year. I'd been a sports reporter. I didn't even know.
She told me I did TaeKwonDo, ballet, gymnastics, track, and field, uh,
learn how to throw a football for my overhand serve.
I worked at a sports magazine. I'd never even heard that. Or, you know,
we think of the Mark. Zuckerberg is like this, the young prodigy, right?
He said, young people are just smarter when he was 22.
He doesn't say that anymore. But last year,
MIT in the us census Bureau released research,
showing that the average age in the U S at least of a founder of a fast-growing
tech startup on the day of founding is 45.4.
But it's just like all these other stories where we focus on these exceptions,
because they're dramatic and they're these tidy narratives.
And we ignore what the research says is actually, uh, the norm,
even though there's a huge amount of variability,
I think it's important to know what's typical when we're all focused on these
exceptions.
I found that, um,
aspect of your book absolutely fascinating because you're right.
We think of the norm as actually, um,
the tiger woods, the kind of young, you know, startup,
and I've certainly seen equivalent studies in other countries where, you know,
you're, um, entrepreneurs on average, a fast growing startup.
So actually in their forties,
people who have had experience and therefore they decided to strike out on their
own. And, um, and yeah, that's not our perception at all.
So I found all of this to be, um, a good reason by the way, David,
to write a book. So let's talk about it and, and change perceptions.
Um,
so I'm going to ask you about the cult of the headstart and the story
of the poker, sisters and chess. Of course, coincidentally,
the Queens gambit on Netflix is garnering attention right now.
Yeah, it's a, and it's a really good show. I watched it, you know,
I think deservedly. So I think like the cinematography is beautiful.
The acting is wonderful, but it's interesting because I just, I just,
the other day did a Q and a where I was the,
the question asker with a guy named John Urschel who used to play in the NFL,
um, getting, you know, American.
And at the same time started his math PhD at MIT at the
same time while he was in the NFL. And now, now he's,
he's a mathematician finishing his, he retired,
decided to retire from the NFL after he had a, you know,
a pretty severe concussion. Um, and he's finishing his PhD in math at MIT,
and he's also, he's become a good chess player.
And his best friend is one of the best chess players in the United States.
And he was talking about Queens gambit and saying how he gets bothered,
sort of by the portrayal of genius in a lot of media where
it's like, just this like bolt of lightning out of the blue rights,
like someone who just has this incredible talent right away, because that's,
that's often not exactly how it works, right.
It's probably not quite as rare as those things make it look,
but it's like usually a slower process. There are,
there are cases that are these sort of bolts out of the blue, but,
but usually it's more, someone gets interested in,
something builds a little skill.
Maybe they learn a little faster than they thought,
and they it's usually much more fits and starts and all sorts of lock-in
coincidences. And there is some of that luck in, in Queens gambit, for sure. Um,
but I think it,
it is just like one more pebble on this huge pile that suggests
either you got it early, or you don't got it at all. And,
and the fact is development is very non-linear and that's usually not
the way these things look and chess by the way is also in many ways,
I think a poor example. So to go back, you mentioned the Polgar story,
that's in the book. So let me, let me talk about that because in some ways it,
it would be interesting to people who've been watching, um, Queens gambit,
so they should go watch, uh, the Polgar variant,
which is a great documentary about the Polgar sisters,
where these three sisters whose father Lazlo decided to train them in chess in a
very technical manner, um, from a young age in Hungary,
and really he didn't care about chess so much.
He just wanted to show that any child with a headstart and so-called deliberate
practice, deliberate practice being like not playing it's very focused,
coached, focused on error,
correction that any kid could become a genius in anything with a headstart and
deliberate practice. And in fact,
two of his daughters went on to become Grandmaster, uh, players.
And one of them went on to become the highest ranked, uh,
woman in the world Judit Polgar. And so this,
this showed up like the tiger woods story in a whole bunch of best-selling books
saying like, this is the key. You just need this, this early start.
And the fact is in chess, it, it actually is, um,
really beneficial to get an early start because chess is based on repetitive
patterns that you have to start recognizing almost like unconsciously.
And if you haven't started studying those by age 12,
the chance of a competitive player go reaching international master status,
which is one down from Grandmaster dropped from about one in four to about one
in 55, you have to start doing that, but that's also why it's so relatively,
so easy to automate, right? Because it's based on these recurring patterns,
the computers are much better at.
And so it's actually a really bad model in many ways of most of the
things like that. We want to learn in the rest of the world or the tiger woods,
like golf being the most famous example,
golf is almost a uniquely bad model of almost everything else that humans want
to learn. So there's nothing wrong with those stories until we extrapolate them,
which is mainly what we do with them, right? So golf and chess. These are,
these are very far on the spectrum of what they're psychologist,
Robin Hogarth called kind learning environments where kind learning environments
are those that have repetitive rules that never change patterns,
that repeat goals.
And next steps are clear feedback as quick and accurate work next year will look
like work last year on the other end of the spectrum of what he called wicked
learning environments, where next steps and goals may not be handed to you.
Rules may not be clear.
They may change feedback may be delayed or an accurate patterns.
Don't just repeat work next year. Won't look like work last year. So like,
which one of these sounds like the world that most of us who aren't like pro
golfers or chess players are living in, right? Some of both, some of both,
but increasingly more of the, of the wicked.
And so it's not that I have a problem with the poker story and they are,
by the way, I should just say they,
in what little interaction I've had with the Polgar sisters,
they seem like lovely well-adjusted people.
I don't think this is a story of like, you know,
kids being turned into monsters by an overbearing father.
But the problem is when we extrapolate those lessons to these other domains
where the lessons don't apply well.
Yeah, absolutely. Um, fascinating. Um,
I recommend everybody get David's book and watch the Queen's gambit too,
as well. That's the other book
I want you to tell the team each of the different parts of this.
So you include so many fascinating study.
So one of the ones that you include is compared to other scientists,
Nobel Laureate. So these are the people at the top of their profession,
normally in science and medicine, and even economics are bad,
I at least, and this is quite extraordinary. Um,
22 times more likely to be an amateur
dancer, magician, or a performer.
So say more about how having range helps these high performers
break, old patterns, um,
which then helps them succeed versus people who are, um,
more specialized. Oh, and, and, and try to, um,
add in a Steve jobs story as well. Cause I think that was also brilliant.
Okay. Yeah. So as musicians, writers, musicians, all these other Fords,
storms, sorts of performers that,
that Nobel Laureate scientists were much more likely to have these sorts of
hobbies compared to typical scientists. And not only that,
but in other studies of, of engineers who made creative contributions, um,
compared to sort of engineers of similar technical skill,
they tended to have aesthetic hobbies outside of work. And again,
in the work of a professor named Abby Griffin who studied so-called serial
innovators,
these are people who make like repeated creative contributions to their
organizations. She found a,
they have tend to have more hobbies than their peers.
They read more and more widely. They have a,
a need to learn outside their discipline.
They have lots of people in their network who are outside of their own
discipline, all these sorts of things that are just, you know,
they just have like wider, longer antennas for the world.
And it seems like in the creative creativity research,
a lot of researchers use different terms for what this is some called,
like network of enterprise.
They have sort of a lot of things that they're interested in. Um,
but it seems to help avoid so-called cognitive entrenchment,
where you sort of get stuck. And, and again,
there are different words for this like functional fixedness means people who,
you know,
they're only able to use a certain type of tool the same way over and over,
and they forget it can be used in different ways or the Einstein lung effect.
Once you've been accustomed to a certain type of solution for a problem,
you get stuck in it, even when it doesn't work for new problems anymore.
And so these are all forms of this cognitive entrenchment,
where with experience you become, you know, with sort of specialized experience,
you, you become much more efficient in certain things,
but there's also a trade-off you can think of it almost like an internet
browser, right? It's like if you go to the same sites all the time,
you'll get cookies and you can go to those sites even faster,
but you're sacrificing some sort of flexibility for searching more broadly.
And so in all this creativity research,
it just showed up over and over and over that the people who made contributions
tended to have like multiple streams of interests often that didn't have
anything to do with one another, like they would have,
they didn't seemingly didn't have one to do with one another.
They would say that it would give them insights into, into some of their work.
Um,
and so I think it's suggested that we want to avoid sort of getting stuck in the
same thought patterns.
You want to have ideas coming from places that aren't just in your,
your direct line of sight every day.
Otherwise you increasingly know the same things that the people in your,
you know, that are around, you know, basically,
and that's where the Steve jobs story comes in. Oh right. The Steve jobs story.
Right. So he, he famously said, I mean, Steve jobs was sort of a, uh,
obviously Apple has very important specialists,
but he was kind of a master generalist, um, in, in many ways.
And he famously said that he, he audited a calligraphy class, uh,
because he was interested in aesthetics and this gave him the idea to have
different type faces. Right. And that led to all computers,
having all these different type faces and a whole bunch of aesthetics that grew
out of that. So it was just this auditing, this class in calligraphy, uh,
they gave him an idea that really changed the aesthetics of,
of personal computing. And he had,
he had a bunch of things like that where he would pick up some, uh,
like he would, he would go and browse stores, you know,
for kitchen supplies or something, and see like, you know, I like,
I like the way this, like blender fits in this spot or whatever maybe we can do.
So he was, he sort of saw the world in the way.
I think like Saul bellow saw when he like walked among people.
He was like shopping for parts of people to put in his characters in the books.
And Steve jobs was like shopping for little aesthetic things when he went around
the world. And so I think he was just like,
I think that was a common theme of what a lot of these,
like these Nobel laureates would do is they really were just curious about the
world. Like they were always, even in their personal time,
they were like shopping for new ideas and sometimes those would end up
influencing their, their main work.
You illustrate, um, the importance of range or the title of your book,
um, using team GV success at the 2012 Olympics.
So tell us that story.
I particularly use this because I was sort of responding to
a British writer who I liked by the way, um, who, who said that, uh,
you know, blame some of the problems of British governance on,
on moving like different ministers into different positions and said, like,
this makes no more sense than moving tiger woods to play hockey or something
like that. And, you know, I think the extreme end of that argument would be,
well, you should just have like a King and they should just like,
stay there all the time. Right. Cause then they'll get the most experience,
but nevermind that. So,
but I thought it was interesting that that team GB, um,
has he made that sports analogy?
I had some insight into some of what was going on to try to,
I mean, Britain quite frankly, had, had, uh,
been gone from being a world sporting powerhouse,
to being very mediocre for four decades and then has bounced back
in, in a big way.
And a lot of that had to do with these programs that were set up to actually
find late bloomers. So as one of the architects of this,
this program and a woman named Chelsea ward told me, she said, well,
we know we have these fast risers, right?
Like the kids who develop physically early or whatever it is,
and people pay tons of attention to them,
but they're like the easiest people to spot. And they're the minority,
it's the slow bakers.
These people that we don't pay attention to who could keep coming around and
being like the most important members of our programs and we don't pay any
attention to them.
So part of the plan was to reform the pipelines so that these people who
developed more slowly wouldn't get kicked out prematurely and you could,
you could, they could keep themselves in,
even if they weren't the best early on.
And a lot of those people go on to become the world champions and Olympians in
some cases, um, do UK set up even these,
these so-called talent transfer, uh,
programs where you can take someone from one sport and just say, you know,
you're not really gonna make it in this one. You want to try some others.
And occasionally things like that would produce Olympians or gold medalists like
Helen Glover, uh, you know, who, who for awhile, it was probably the,
a rower who was probably the most dominant athlete in the world.
She got spotted in a talent search in Britain. She won,
I think the first her and her,
her teammate won the first gold medal for the home team at the 2012 Olympics.
She had not road as of the previous Olympics ever. Right? So these are,
this goes really against these 10,000 hours of, well, if you didn't start early,
uh, you lost. And I think, um, you know,
some countries that have realized that that is,
that's not the case have really capitalized on it in,
in diversifying their developmental pipeline to capture some of the, you know,
late bloomers, which typically make up the greater portion of,
of the people who go to the top.
And you write about a variety of paths to excellence,
which all involve the sampling period when you just described your sort of
sample sports and various things.
So I must get you to tell us the story of Duke Ellington. Um,
that was just a great example of a different paths.
Definitely not starting early. So.
Course this came out of my personal interest because I think he's a jazz
musician, um, a, uh,
through his art in important social critic at the time. Um,
and he, he creatively reinvented like his most famous work.
If you Google it as stuff from the thirties, this big band music,
which honestly sounds a little bit like cheesy to my ear, to the modern ear.
But then if you look at his stuff in the sixties,
that people are less familiar with,
it is you would never know as the same musician. And it is amazing,
like go to YouTube, listen to Florette African, um, with Duke Ellington,
it's totally different music and it's, it's very modern and, and incredible.
Um, but he actually had an offer of music lessons when he was a kid from this,
I love the name of his, the teacher. He was offered Marietta clink scales. Um,
and he decided not to do it because he wasn't interested at the time he was
focused on baseball and painting and drawing. He actually was offered, uh,
an art scholarship to college, but turned it down. And it was only, you know,
it was about seven years after that.
And he was a teenager where he heard ragtime and said, you know,
now that that I'm interested in.
And then he went to the piano himself and started trying started trying to copy
and work things out. And a theme for him became that he was,
he wanted to go and immerse himself and sort of try and experiment and learning
by sort of being told, do this over and over and over, um,
was not the thing for him. And I think,
I think that is sort of in fact, I mean,
he became at one time the preeminent creative composer in the United States,
and he was still using some of his own made up notation because he had never
formally learned like real musical notation and people had to sort of like
transcribe it for him. And that,
that sort of is in line with a lot of research that suggests, look,
if you're just looking to try to play classical music,
then this huge amount of repetition. Absolutely.
But if you're looking to create and compose, then sometimes this,
this process that is much slower at the beginning where you sort of dive in and
fail and are immersed and it should be more like the way we learn language,
right? Like you don't get taught grammar first. You, you,
you jump in and you try and you fail and later if ever
you learn the grammar. Right. I, I mean, I'm a writer. I, I don't know.
I know very little about grammar is kind of, well,
I'm not embarrassed by it anymore because now, but like, you know,
my in-laws sometimes still make fun of me because I don't know,
like formal rules of grammar. And I'm like, but it's okay. I mean,
I'm living with professional writers.
So obviously it's not holding me back in the same way that many of the great
jazz musicians either learn to read music late or never learned to read music
late. And so when they had to learn early on, it was as much initially slower,
but more immersive creative experimental process that,
that grew very organically into their creativity.
I love that.
To joke that you mentioned in the book when a jazz musician is asked,
um, can you read music? The answer is not enough to affect my plate,
not enough to hurt my plan. Um, David's actually fascinating.
I want to kind of get into now some of the, um, the concepts, um,
but all these stories illustrate. So, um,
I'm going to rattle through a couple of them and, um, get you to elaborate.
So reasoning by broad analogy.
So we've touched on that already.
That's sort of one of the takeaways another takeaway is, and this,
this is very interesting, um,
why you have to set aside expertise sometimes, um,
cause there's a problem of deep and specialized expertise.
So just kind of talk us through that.
Yeah. So I think one of the, um,
the problems with expertise sometimes, and again, I,
I don't mean to suggest that we, we don't need it,
but is the over use of solutions that may have
worked in certain situations or that people have gotten used to,
even if they don't work anymore.
So to give one sort of stunning example like there, um,
some interesting work by an economist recently in two S two Harvard led studies
that found that in the U S again, it's specific to us.
If you're checked into academic hospitals.
So hospitals associated with universities with certain cardiac conditions,
like a heart attack and the dates of a national cardiology convention,
when the most esteemed specialists are away, you're less likely to die.
And the conclusion the researchers made is that there's a lower rate of these
very intensive procedures.
That specialists are very used to doing over and over,
even though the evidence has shown either that they don't work in certain
situations, you know, they're, they're dangerous or they're ineffective or both,
and yet they keep doing it anyway.
And initially this was thought maybe to be these sorts of phenomenon to be
coupled to compensation, right.
But then some institutions tried to decouple the number of times you do a
procedure from compensation and it still stayed. So it's a deeper bias.
And if you go look in specialist journals,
you'll see even when overwhelming evidence contradicts some practice,
they'll say, but I've seen it work. Right. Which of course,
the reason we have science is because you can't just tell at work from having
seen something work.
And so you can get this effect where people do things
like without thinking about it really, or in a situation that's changed,
or even in spite of evidence. And one of the examples I use later the book, um,
come from a psychologist named Carl White, who studied, uh, organizations that,
that have to perform under high pressure and high reliability. And so they,
they train really a lot, you know,
over and over and over and over to create so-called muscle memory.
And then the problem sort of becomes when a situation changes and they do those
same things anyway.
So something like 80% of commercial air traffic, uh,
accidents happen because a flight crew sticks to like the familiar procedure,
even when to an outsider,
it's clear that the situation has changed or is why one of his famous examples
was in wilderness, uh, wilderness firefighters where, you know,
they'll either hike in or parachute into a fire's fire fire,
and try to dig a trench around it. And they're very elite, you know,
highly trained professionals.
And they do a really good job except occasionally something unexpected happens
like a fire jumps from one hillslope to another and starts chasing them uphill.
And what he,
what he found unusual in those cases is that when there would be a tragedy and
there'd be loss of life and bodies would be recovered,
they would often still have like 200 pounds of equipment on them.
Only 50 feet away from where they could have run to safety.
And what he learned was that they would not,
they were unwilling to drop their tools. So he used this phrase,
drop their tools, um,
which meant to dispense with your familiar procedures when the situation has
changed, but they were so highly trained, never to get rid of your tools.
Your tools are part of your identity as a wilderness firefighter.
They save your life that even when they were being commanded to do so,
drop your tools and run, they would not do so.
And they would die holding their tools.
And eventually this finding actually led to diversification of training in some
of these areas where people are,
have more improvisation built into their training,
but he saw this issue of dropping your tools as sort of an allegory for a
variety of industries where people continue doing something they're used to,
even when the problem in front of them has changed.
Um, um, I want to focus on one more aspect, um,
which is grit. So you write that grit has two parts,
a work ethic and resilience, and a second part,
which is knowing exactly what one wants.
So tell us the beast story and, um, and why,
um,
how that story and grit predicts success better than comprehensive scores and
all the kinds of things that we're used to looking at.
Yeah. So grit, like you said, again, just a quick refresher for I've,
everyone's probably heard the term, but it's,
it's a psychological construct based on a 12 question survey,
half the points awarded for persistence of effort like perseverance and the
other for so-called consistency of interests, you know,
knowing what you want to do and just that,
and it became really famous with the work of Angela Duckworth.
Another person I really liked by the way, um,
w when she did research at the U S military Academy, um,
so-called West point and the grit survey turned out to be a better predictor of
who would survive beast. The,
the initial orientation that's very physically and emotionally rigorous.
Um,
it was a better predictor than were traditional things like tests of athleticism
and, and standardized tests and, you know, other traditional evaluations.
And so I think that was surprise and something that was very interesting. Um,
it also turned out to have some predictive value for who would graduate as did
those traditional measures. And so that's, that's interesting thing to know the,
the part of it that I critiqued was, um, if you,
so those West,
but the point of West point is not to make these survivors or graduates is to
make the future leaders of the organization in this case, the U S army.
So they have a five-year active duty commitment after they graduate fully
funded. And since about the mid 1990s, after those five years,
almost half of them quit like on the day that they were allowed.
So suddenly these very gritty people are dropping like flies, and this and this,
this phenomenon started really in the mid nineties.
So some high ranking officers said, Oh, we have a millennial grip problem.
You know, like, I don't know too much avocado toast,
not enough mortgages or something. I don't know what the exact idea was,
but they thought they had developed a grid problem overnight.
And then a group of officers and researchers decided to study the problem and
found they had not, in fact, developed a grit problem, overnight surprise,
surprise. They had developed a match quality problem. So they were,
they had this traditional structure of you assign someone a career.
They can express preferences,
but you assigned them a career track and they get up or out.
And that worked quite well when the rest of our economy was like that with very
little or lateral mobility.
People had discreet periods of training followed by discrete period of work,
where they would do the same thing,
but then enter the knowledge economy and information economy.
And that goes out the window.
And now we prize people who can engage in creative problem,
solving knowledge creation, who are adaptable.
And so these young people start realizing things about themselves in their late
teens and early twenties and realize they have no agency over career matching in
the army. So they would leave to do it outside.
And first the army tried to throw money at them. Um, and that didn't work.
The ones who are going to stay took the money,
the ones are going to leave left anyway, half a billion dollars,
taxpayer money down the drain.
Then they started programs like one called talent based branching,
where instead of saying, here's your career track, get up or out.
They pair these cadets with like a coach or like a mentor.
They let them sample like five different career tracks,
reflect on how each one fits them and,
and learn about themselves as they go 90% of the cadets who went through that
talent based branching program changed their career preference, 90% of them,
and that improved retention where money hadn't.
And so I think as one of the researchers in this area told me, when you get fit,
it looks like grit.
Meaning if you get people in work that fits their interests and abilities, well,
they will display characteristics of grit, even if they didn't before.
And so it's not that I don't think grit is important,
but I think the evidence suggests that there's an even higher return to good
match because people will then display those characteristics, uh, of,
of grit anyway. Um, so that was sort of where I think grit is both important,
but also some of our extrapolations about it have been
just like with the tiger woods story have been ill-conceived. And by the way,
Angela Duckworth is she feels the same way.
So I highly recommend Google summer is for sampling. It's her,
it's a edition of her newsletter that came out like a day before my book.
And it talks a little bit about some of these,
these misconceptions of Google summaries for sampling Angela Duckworth.
Lovely. Um, again, gonna squeeze in one more story for you to tell,
because I think it's a great story to wrap up with, um,
before I get you to just kind of sum up, um, our takeaways.
I want you to tell us the story of the first time CEO, um,
who was also her first professional job at the age of 54,
and she never went to college.
So you ride that uncommon career paths are actually
common and they're not that rare.
So illustrates the importance of short-term planning.
So tell us that story and about short-term plan.
Yeah. And she was, she had one semester of junior college, that's it? Um,
so this is a woman named Frances Hesselbein, um,
who grew up in sort of industrial town in Pennsylvania.
And basically her career strategy or lack thereof really was,
as she said, do what's needed at the time.
So she would volunteer in her community, or her husband, uh,
had been a military photographer and came back and started a photo store.
And she would just sort of, she was the literal Jack of all trades.
Like if somebody had a weird request, it was like, Francis,
just go figure it out. Like, I remember one story, she told me it was somebody,
someone came in with their dog and said, I want you to take a photo of them,
but I want it to look like a painting, you know, like an oil painting.
It's like, all right, Francis go like, figure out how to do that.
And so she was just a sort of Jack of all trades and, and in her mid, uh,
and she, she started volunteering with the girl Scouts eventually.
And she didn't really want to,
but someone from our neighborhood came around and said, look,
we're going to have to disband this group of girls,
unless someone like volunteers to be their leader.
And so Francis does it and says, I'll do it for a few months,
but then she just keeps doing it and keeps doing and keeps doing it.
And she gets more involved in girl Scouts. And at age 54,
she takes her first professional job as sort of a regional director of the girl
Scouts basically. And then she just starts every time she never wants to.
She always says no to the things. Every time somebody offers her something,
she always says, no, like shortly after that,
which he had said no to someone comes to her and says, look,
we need you to lead the United way fundraising campaign for girl Scouts because
it's in disarray. And if you don't, then we're just gonna, you know, we're,
it's just girl Scouts are gonna lose the partnership. And Francis like fine.
If the first she says no. And then she says, well,
if they're gonna lose the partnership, I'll do it.
So she's the first woman to do this. And Johnstown,
Pennsylvania like leads the country in, in giving that year.
And so it's this huge success. Eventually in her sixties,
she goes on to become the CEO of the girl Scouts. Again, something she says no,
when they ask her, because the previous,
the previous leaders of the Scouts had been like a woman who started the us
coast guard reserve and a university Dean.
These people with incredible leadership credentials,
France said one semester of junior college.
And it was one of like 350 regional directors. And,
but again, once again,
she'd sort of decides to do it and under a little bit of pressure.
And because the organization was tanking early seventies,
society changing for girls and women, a lot of girl Scouts,
not changing very much. So it was in a tailspin losing membership,
losing volunteers. She comes in, throws out all the traditional stuff, right.
Which was one of the big moves because they could not the people who are more
steeped in it could not like they had campsites that people weren't using,
but there was so much nostalgic value. They wouldn't get rid of them.
And she was like, we gotta, we gotta save the organization,
rip up the one handbook, make all these handbooks tailored to, um,
her target audiences recreate the leadership team to look like the audience that
she wants to serve. As she said, I want, if a,
if an indigenous girl on an ice flow in Alaska opens our book,
I want her to see herself in a, um, uh, in a girl Scouts manual. Again,
this is in the seventies and she saves the organization.
She triples minority membership. She has 130,000 volunteers.
So it turns the cookie business into a third of a billion dollars a year.
Whether it's various crises, changes it from an organization,
preparing girls for life in the home to one,
preparing them for careers in math and science. She gave me, Oh,
I guess I did a podcast. We wouldn't be able to see it,
but a badge that came out of her tenures,
binary code for girls learning about computers, um, and it,
and she turned the whole thing, uh, around,
she changed the hierarchical structure to when she called circular management,
because she knew she didn't have enough specialty to get all the information she
needed. She needed information flowing from more levels of the organization.
And after that, she tried to retire.
And like two days after that got a call from someone saying,
we have an office for you. Come take it. You'll figure out what to do later,
which is what she had always done in her life anyway.
And she started a leadership Institute that she still runs works five days a
week in Manhattan. And she just turned 105 earlier this month. So,
uh, who knows what's next for Francis, but it was,
I just used it as this extreme emblematic symbol of this,
this greater research that I profiled called the dark horse project that talks
about how people find work that fits them really well.
And basically the pattern was they could have long-term goals, but if so,
they didn't hold to them very tightly. What they really did was say,
here's why I'm right now, here are the options in front of me.
I'm going to do this one.
And maybe a year from now will change because I will have learned something
about myself or my options will have changed.
And they just keep on doing that over and over, like throughout their,
their lifetime until they find better and better matches. And so she's,
she sort of occurred to me as an extreme version of that. And also frankly,
as someone whose story,
I think deserved a lot more attention that the famous management guru,
Peter Drucker at one point called her the greatest CEO in America.
So she deserves more attention.
Great story to end with. Um, but David, before we wrap up,
I want you to sum up what are your tips, um, to,
uh, for our, um, for those who are tuning in, um,
to become a generalist who try it?
Yeah. So first don't worry about being behind because, uh,
development is so nonlinear, whether that's physical development or your,
your, you know, career development, um, that we are,
our intuition is to see people at a space in time and assume that's a stable
trajectory and that's not, that's just not the case. It's almost never the case.
Um, so don't, don't feel behind it. Doesn't help you.
You don't even know where you're going, but I think an approach,
like I just mentioned those dark horse, the dark horse project people,
a lot of those people ended up with this incredibly broad skillset,
but typically they didn't set out to say like, I'm going to be a generalist.
They set out in search of match quality for their work,
and they would go somewhere and find, um, you know, and you, you only,
you only learn about yourself by doing stuff. My,
my favorite quote in ranges from Herminia Ibarra,
London business school professors, did we learn who we are in practice,
not in theory,
like there's all this personality quiz industry that wants to convince you that
you can just look inside yourself and know what to do.
When in fact you have to do stuff and then reflect on how it fits you,
what you were good at and bad at.
And so these people would take this approach of,
of trying things to figure out about themselves and then pivoting in response to
that, those lessons in that lived experience. And by doing that,
they would end up with this by being curious about themselves and their options,
they would end up with these broad skills.
And so I would say you don't even have to set out to be a generalist,
be curious, diversify your sources of information,
be open-minded and try to get the maximum amount of learning from
each of your experiences about yourself. What surprised you,
what interested you that you didn't expect?
What were you good or bad at that you didn't expect?
That was another surprise in that,
in the Army's talent based branching research,
the cadets were often surprised by things that they weren't as good at as they
thought they would be or interested in things they didn't think they would be
interested in. And so make sure you,
you make the most of those lessons and then don't ignore them like pivot in
response to them. You know, it's, it's, I think we,
everyone wants like a linear looking LinkedIn, you know,
but we shouldn't reward people for forging ahead.
If they learn things that say they should pivot. And in fact,
LinkedIn's own research on a half,
a million members showed that the best predictor of who would go on to become an
executive was the number of different job functions someone had worked at.
And yet you could argue that their product might Augur against people feeling
like they should do that. And so I think we should just don't,
you know, don't be scared to try different things, um, and,
and pivot in response to the things you're learning,
take every different opportunity to try something as, um,
an opportunity to learn about yourself and your options.
I forced myself to do it. I keep something.
I called a book of small experiments, right?
Forced myself to investigate something new at least every other month.
And so I think it'd be good if we all had systems for forcing ourselves to
diversify our learning a little bit or try new things.
Because once you get competent at something,
most people will settle into that thing and keep doing it at a certain level
forever. If you want to continually get better, you have to do different things.
You can't lift the same weight at the same number of times every day and expect
to get better. You might not get worse, but you won't get better.
So find methods to diversify,
don't feel behind and pivot in response to the pay attention,
to the lessons you're learning, reflect on them and pivot in response to them.
Great summary, thank you so much. Um, David Epstein,
I encourage everyone to pick up his book range.
Why generalists triumph in a specialized world?
It's a lively read and they're huge. Um,
a number of just fascinating examples,
including when we didn't have time to get to, but I absolutely loved,
which was the story of van Gogh, the painter.
And I think once you read the book,
it'll inspire you to start thinking differently about your path
forward or paths forward.
So thanks very much again to David Epstein and thank you all for tuning in for
more business podcasts, go to intelligence squared.com. I'm Linda. You.
Great. Thanks guys. That was, that was really interesting.
I learned a lot myself there. I love the stories.
Tell I have a very digressive brain.
So as basically as digressive as my book is that's me being organized in my
thinking. So.
Your summary was great.
I just wanted to give you a chance to summarize because there's so many never
covered everything, but it was so interesting. I found the book counselor.
They interesting, so many different.